It is in part that and part to mimic
our collective memories.
All of us that,
um,
memories of strange thing that if you
think about it,
how much of today do I remember?
Well,
I could,
it's already abstracted,
but I've already of course,
utterly obliterated almost every
syllable to come out of my mouth.
It's gone.
It's history.
What about yesterday?
I can't remember every dish I washed,
every scab I picked,
every person I encountered,
it's,
it's every meal.
I ate hundreds and thousands of them.
And I would say that out of my life,
99%,
probably a lot more than that.
It's been a race that is biliterate it
erase,
can't remember a detail.
Uh,
and I'm not just talking about
childhood,
I'm talking about a Delta and people
I've cared deeply about it.
And I remember them and loving ways and
yet have a few snapshots of memory.
And we hold onto those and we call a
memory.
And that's memory,
that little
remnant of,
of a lifetime.
That's what's left to us.
And we attach this word memory to it,
which cylons has a silent of
encompassing all.
But it doesn't,
and that certainly applies to the things
they carried.
I mean it's a book partly about memory.
The author of that book is an older guy
and he's looking back and he's recycling
event from different angles,
sometimes inventing things as a way of
seeking that which is,
is gone
ghostly
a good friendship.
Merrick who stepped on a landmine and
was blown into this tree and uh,
he's been dead a long time.
And yet in the writing of the things
they carried,
I tried to sunway resurrect through
imagination.
What is last thoughts may have been as
he sorted into that tree as sunlight is
killing me.
I know I'm making it up,
but I'm trying to sort of cast a light
on that which has been darkened by,
by a history in the passage of time to
let chip keeps soaring.
Hey,
you know,
you said as long as I book is Rad,
that guy's going to keep soaring into
that hedge for you know,
and that tree and as long as the book is
Rad Little Linda at the end of the book,
is it going to keep skating on that ice?
And Little Timmy will be in love with
her and skating along.
And that is what
you don't,
you're not.
So I'm not saving their bodies,
and I'm not even saving the memories of
these people really.
But I'm saving something like you hope
that's essential and enduring,
and the human spirit,
the love of a little boy for a little
girl and a good friend who soared into a
tree and a terrible war.
And that's something,
it's not everything,
but it's something.